yeah what's going on man this week this
past week has been good
it's been good it's been you know i had
some moments where i was really like
you know what am i doing how am i gonna
kind of make this
work this feels uncomfortable um
you know i had a day where i didn't want
to do anything
you know was really feeling uh down in
the dumps
um you know and thankfully there's mo i
have moments in that day where it's like
okay just
you know yeah maybe half the day hasn't
gone well but let's get the other half
let's salvage this other half of this
day and let's go um
you know one of the beauties of of uh
just of the past few years has been
meeting guys and being able to come into
worlds
um you know like
you know joe rogan you meet joe rogan
you get into his universe and know him
and you get inspired and then you start
you know following guys like david
goggins and reading their books and
jocko willink and um
and uh cam haines and and uh
and you start getting i guess it's like
inspirational type of guys you have
dustin poirier come in and sit down
you know um and you just it
it's interesting i start to realize that
i
i almost
thankfully i almost know too many people
now who don't give up
to give up like for like a full day
sometimes if that makes any sense it's
it's just like uh it it's like oh if you
stack your deck of cards with enough
cards that
you know if you take some of the fives
out of your deck and you
throw in a couple extra jacks you know
something with a sword
you throw in an a couple extra jokers
you know
a couple extra beefy jokers you know
some riddler some juggler using
using test 200 or something and now you
got a deck of
you know you got a deck of cards that
are it's a little bit stronger it's a
little bit more like
inspirational i guess yeah i guess i've
just found myself getting more into
you know i know enough inspirational
people almost personally
um
where yeah it's just interesting it
almost makes it harder for me to give up
on myself a little bit
um i don't know what i'm saying really
good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could
watch this one or watch this one watch
this one watch this one
watch this one